un incendie s'est déclaré dans le tunnel
de la gare routière de saint quentin en
yvelines
les derniers passagers sont évacués
problème un bus est passé malgré l'
alerte dans le cadre d'un exercice réel
ça pourrait être un gros problème
puisque la station souterraine étant
évacués on peut avoir des phénomènes de
fumée et de flammes qui met en péril les
voyageurs
là pour le coup c'est une petite
défaillance qu'on doit corriger tous les
accès sont bouclés par les agents de
sécurité
[Musique]
les pompiers interviennent sur l'
incendie et tentent d'évacuer une
personne de la zone dangereuse ski bus
agents de sécurité et pompiers sont
mobilisés sur cet exercice planifié par
la préfecture
objectif tester la validité des
consignes et les interactions entre les
différents acteurs lors de l'opération
sous l'oeil attentif des agents de
montigny le bretonneux et de saint
quentin en yvelines
je rappelle que les garçons sous
l'autorité des préfets
donc on a un sérieux qui sont jamais de
des plans de sécurité assemblés sur ce
domaine nous on y participe
appel des secours évacuation des
passagers coordination des équipes la
gestion de l'opération est réalisée au
pc de sécurité
je suis satisfait ça s'est bien passé
les informations ont été transmises les
agents ont fait le travail qu'il fallait
pour moi pas de problème quoi un nouvel
exercice devrait être prévue au début de
l'année 2017